it is the biggest U.S intelligence leak
in decades dramatic video showing the
FBI arresting 21-year-old National
Guardsman Jack Tashara he is accused of
stealing our nation's most sensitive
Secrets including highly classified
documents on the war in Ukraine and
details about our allies and enemies and
it was all apparently to impress a bunch
of his teenage friends in a video game
chat room The Washington Post
interviewing one of the members who says
to Shara acted like a father figure to
the group during covid
it felt like I was on top of Mount
Everest it felt like I was above
everyone else to some degree and that um
I would I would be able to brag to some
people that I knew stuff that they
didn't he is not interested in helping
any foreign agencies with their attack
on the U.S or other countries he was he
was a young charismatic Man Who Loved
nature God and bottom line if they want
these to be private it's because they
have something to hide
so the Biden Administration appears to
have been caught flat-footed by this
Major League to Shara was essentially an
I.T worker with the highest level of
security clearance and access to
military Intel systems he had been
circulated information for months online
but the Pentagon only learning about it
last week through the media the dod
dodging how damaging this could be
how did this happen and isn't this a
massive security breach again we need to
allow the investigation to run its
course we'll of course know more when
that is completed so I'd refer you to to
doj on that you put into context the
damage that has been done by this leak
again right now we're continuing to
assess the scope and the impact and so
that's work that will be ongoing
President Biden downplaying the
significance of the league just hours
before the arrest
I'm not concerned about the Lincoln news
and I'm concerned that it happened but
there's nothing contemporaneous that I'm
aware of that is of great concept all
right let's talk about Jack Jack Tashara
21 years old Greg now in FBI custody
after this I mean it is a major I
was gonna say Shenanigans sorry sorry
Shenanigans after these Shenanigans but
that's such a common word but the thing
is is that shenanigans
that downplays it too much because it is
serious but it's also like online gaming
chat everything about this is
2023. you know a 21 year old I.T worker
in a game chat room sharing Secrets uh I
by the way and I'm not gonna I I should
never get a security clearance I think
it's pretty clear I have a big mouth uh
I say everything don't ever confide in
me on anything I will tell everybody I'm
careless this is why I don't want to I I
I somebody found my checkbook on the
street yesterday in front of my house
just sitting there only an idiot would
do that see I I I'm I'm an expert at
carelessness we have to have higher
standards here if a 21 year old I.T
worker can get a security clearance
anybody can including somebody unstable
and dangerous like me now but I I do I
want to say I used to get upset about
Intel leaks because it puts lives at
risks at risk but I don't trust any
information that we're getting anymore
from our government or from Ukraine or
Russia I mean you know what if in that
leaking material was actual truth right
I mean we seem to remember you know
Obama saying that we were winning the
Afghan war and that the Taliban were
being destroyed and that's the reason we
draw down the troops and then of course
we find out that's all Bs uh we were we
were always we're always being lied to
about the tide of War that's the thing
that we will always be told that
everything's going great so we keep
investing in it you can't trust anybody
some that kid would say was saying
basically you know what I like to cut of
that kid's jib not you right yeah it was
me what do you think of the teenage
online chat I mean I don't know how to
share a new that the people that were in
his little group chat thing were how do
you know that that's not a spy on the
other end yeah well Dan everybody knows
you put your classified documents next
to a Corvette you don't put them on a
chat group and the guy has to get a
girlfriend I mean you're on a gaming
chat room go outside
and he's from Massachusetts so I think
we can all
understand what's going on there yes
I don't trust anything about this story
I'm with Greg
this is more than the fog of War I
assume the government's lying to me I
assume the media is lying to me so when
they say this thing's all wrapped up and
it's some gamer in Massachusetts that
leaked this thing I don't know I don't
even know if these leaks are real I
don't know if they're half real half
true disinformation if it's all good I
don't even know I don't even know if I'm
allowed to read
the leaks does Fox News have a policy
that we are we yeah I think you can read
them but if you actually if you this is
kind of weird if you have a classified
security clearance you are not allowed
to read them okay even though they're on
the front page of the New York Times
okay so the other thing is I read
something that 5 000 individuals have
access to this material
that is way too many people
like 220 000.
but maybe to the specific material I I
read it was 5 000 people have access to
this
why are why is everybody in the
government a contractor now ever it's
this is like the rise of the contractors
these defense contractors they have all
of the information
and the defense contractors are running
all of our bases all of our Data Systems
all of our weapon systems it's not just
the Pentagon there's a few people in the
Pentagon right but there's Millions more
contractors spread throughout the entire
world so
this is just one guy this could be
happening all over the place so I don't
know what to make of it uh it looks like
we're spying on our friends and our
enemies and everyone's trying to stab
each other in the back and get paid and
that's standard and that's and they know
that we're spying on them but they're
trying to spy on us Etc Jessica but get
your thoughts on this well the butt is
now they can hold a press conference
like the Chinese did and say this is
what's going on in America and anytime
that you give them an upper hand even
though we all know that it's a bunch of
BS in the way that they do things is not
as good as the way that we do things it
ends up not looking great for us the
president said I'm not concerned about
the leaks I think there should be a
little bit of a ban on that term we had
that also with the Chinese spy balloon
not concerned about it they didn't get
anything out of it just say we don't
know at this point we are hopeful that
this was all outdated information it
seems like the positioning of the troops
and how much Ukraine had seems to be
outdated it but when something is moving
this quickly and it's so complicated you
can't really be sure of anything
um obviously it seems like it's out of a
movie you know 20 or 30 teens and young
20 year olds sitting around in the thug
Shaker Central chat room
exchanging God knows what kinds of
information other than this I want to
say something though about who figured
this out and the people who are so ahead
of the curve or ahead of our government
like the folks at bellingcat so they
were the first ones to actually come up
with this they were before the
Washington Post they have now been given
credit and now the rebelling cat of
folks that are on the bylines with the
New York Times reporters our government
is behind some of our Legacy Media is
even behind what people who have better
command of the internet are capable of
doing so that's people who work at these
organizations and Valencia brought us
the Panama papers a few years ago and
then just also random people that are
really good at snooping around the
internet and we have to catch up that's
actually not new if you remember in 2004
in that election when you had Rob Louis
who was looking at the Dan rather's
forged documents kind of nail George W
bush which backfired of course yeah
Katie this guy the Father Figure 21 year
old gamer
who also was a reservist who had a top
secret clearance what do you think
happens to him now that he's in custody
I mean they're going to go after him
pretty hard in the prosecution yeah I'm
I'm going to need a lot more information
about the situation before I'm willing
to hang this guy or even say that he's
guilty
um I talked to a few people today who
are in the security Arena who have
clearances about this kind of situation
and they think it's kind of weird
um you remember when Benghazi happened
and there was a security breach and it
was the administration's fault and they
were requesting security for the embassy
it never came and then all of a sudden
there's a terrorist attack and people
are killed including the U.S ambassador
and they arrested a filmmaker randomly
and said it was a YouTube video problem
and they lied so I'm not really sure I
believe what they're telling us about
the situation given that this
information that John Kirby essentially
said was at was was authentic by
berating the press for reporting on it
um all of a sudden President Biden's
strategy in Ukraine what she's been
saying is working gets revealed as
failing because the ukrainians are going
to run out of ammunition in May they're
not winning against Russia as we've been
told that they are and now all of a
sudden they've tracked down an I.T guy a
reservist in Maryland to say that he's
the one who did it I mean I just think
that there's gonna be a lot more to the
story and given the fact that they have
lied about this that the Afghanistan
papers which is a great book by Craig
Whitlock revealed that for decades they
were lying to us about the progress of
the war it's the same pattern and so
while we're talking about the guy who
possibly did this we're not talking
about what the information revealed
which is that the government has been
telling us one thing and their reality
on the ground is quite different okay so
that heaping amount of skepticism on all
that but we'll keep you updated as it
progresses I winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on box you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now